hello in the South Creek guy remember it
so you don't have to the best villains
come from the most unlikely places don't
they who would have thought such a
seemingly kind magical and enchanting
Enterprise could turn out so many
diabolical geniuses how they also made
them good movie villains do ou still
Disney is known for having some of the
best movie villains in cinematic history
Maleficent Frollo Gaston scar Lady
Tremaine the list goes on
all of these baddies stay with us as
some of the most deliciously despicable
characters that we love to hate they
range in appearance and personality yes
they're always distinctly Despicable
which makes them typically enjoyable
these are villains that have and will be
remembered for years so um what happened
don't get me wrong Disney villains in
today's animated films are perfectly
serviceable they're mean develop imprint
of a story but are you one saying hey
you know who the next Maleficent is that
old guy from up you know gimme that
chills as much as Frollo like the huggin
bear these are not necessarily bad
villains but they're not one who were
really talked about much either they do
their job but don't go beyond the call
of duty it's safe to say they're not
going to be in that many villain lineup
so when Disney tries to sell their
merchandise that's also not to say that
all the past Disney villains are
perfection either adult Edgar is going
to be on any top-ten list or the horn
King Sykes and asshole deer so there's
no doubt that people can name a lot more
villains from the older days of Disney
than the more recent days Shere Khan the
Queen of Hearts korilla De Vil Jafar
whether for comedy misery or both they
just had more personalities that stick
with us so why is this happening
were there just more memorable bad guys
in the old days or is there a distinct
difference between how Disney does
villains now compared to how they used
to do them before
or the builds of nowadays just don't
leave their mark as strongly as their
predecessors I guess we should clarify
what qualifies is that well I guess it
means being a villain that people love
to watch whether humorous are scary
they're the characters you could see
starring in their own movie in fact some
of them even did well but they did in my
opinion the last really great Disney
villain that people love to quote is
hating he was energized funny menacing
and considered by many to be the best
part of the movie this was the last real
scene stealer so how come the majority
that came after him don't stand out as
much even though they do their job
perfectly fine well first let's look at
the numbers there's just a lot more
Disney films technology has stepped up
businesses boomed then Disney has pushed
out a lot more flakes because of this
it's more likely that we overlook some
films that had good antagonist as yours
down under edge or see Scott voicing an
evil poacher and having the time of his
life but it got lost in the winter rush
the few people remember him or have even
seen the movie Treasure Planet had a
pretty complex villain one of the
best-known in literary history and
portrayed pretty strong but because and
drawn films are on the way out few
people saw this one too on top of that
with more movies coming out there's more
of a rush to meet deadlines not that
there isn't unns of time to vote it to
these villains and that doesn't clearly
show but big-budget animated films used
to produce a film roughly every three to
four years now it's a minimum of one a
year meaning the time they had to
develop villains was also expanded but
even when more films started to come out
there was still some pretty cool nemec's
CCB's earth allah Jafar gift on and so
forth however as time went on a new
focus was starting to take center stage
you see what I made films first came out
there were so mind-blowing that you
didn't always need the best story now
white is a simple fairy tale with simple
characters and the story ran on a more
emotional logic than logical logic
therefore there was more focus on how to
get feelings from the visuals rather
than what they were saying
so the nasty imagery was very nasty to
make the pleasant imagery seem all the
more rewarding so back then it made more
sense to have the villains and their
surroundings be more creative
design focus and as terrifying as
possible just look at Sleeping Beauty
nobody really remembers the
personalities of the print of the
princess but they all remember the
personality of the villain the darrell
is nice enough to want to root for it
but it's more out of the fear of how
controlling and dominating her
stepmother is that's what made the
happily-ever-after it seemed all the
more happy because it harnessed the
emotion of fear
bottom line making the villains more
interesting with not only more fun for
the animators to draw think about
they're not usually allowed to depict up
cat imagery and something for kids but
it also made the cheerful moments all
the more cheerful going through your
everyday life is fine but if you survive
a horrible threat that same day can feel
pretty amazing
this was the tactic that was cleverly
used by Disney but the problem is it did
it too well some of the main characters
were coming across a too dull without
enough traits to make them unique an
element mock later by Disney themselves
in movies like enchanted so Disney has a
focus on what you could argue they
should have been focusing on the whole
time the main characters Prince's went
from having almost no lines to being
charming likable guys and princesses
went from elegant blandness to
expressive and energized personality
more time was being put into making them
more relatable and updated taking time
away from making the villain more nasty
mother got now in the Shadow Man are not
bad villain but more time is on our
leads than them
not allowing as much time to shine as
there was in the past but maybe that's
for the best the villains that we seemed
on par with their heroes rather than
upstaging them they still got attention
and we love to fear injure them however
the classic fairy tale good versus evil
was going to be challenged by more
modern audiences if characters were
going to be more three-dimensional and
complex the heroes needed more flaws and
the villains needed more humanity free
character writing often acknowledges
people aren't just born good or bad
they're made by their surroundings
which are often addressed in good
stories to understand them better people
were evolving beyond the basic good
versus evil story they want something
more interesting more challenging more
human us began Disney's latest craze the
unknown villain what do I mean by this I
mean I'm going to go into spoilers for
all of these movies just to talk about
their villains y'all remember when Sixth
Sense came out and suddenly every movie
needed to have a twist at the end well
not only did Disney catch on to that
craze but it often made sense to use to
get their message across
movies like Zootopia frozen Atlantis
Tarzan Treasure Planet wall-e wreck-it
Ralph up Monsters Inc big hero 6 and Toy
Story 2 and 3 all have surprise villains
there people made to look like average
characters but are either halfway or
even at the end revealed to be the bad
guys this takes time away from focusing
on them being evil and thus are not
given enough time to usually be
developed at least as they were in the
past now don't get me wrong this has
been used before and very cleverly till
my favorite villains are guest on from
Beauty and the Beast and Sid from Toy
Story but both of these villains work in
a very organic way Gaston is the same
throughout the entire film he's
egotistical funny intimidating and
what's nothing but Belle by the end he's
exactly the same but the circumstances
have pushed him to fight harder for what
he wants and we as the audience members
see him for the threat that he is Cinda
many respect is similar but works a
little differently you know he's not a
good kid but you also know he's just a
kid nothing he's doing is illegal or
evil just a troublemaker being a
troublemaker by the end his motivation
is still the same but he's pushed it to
a point where the toys fight back
forcing him to see more of his childish
humanity both of these characters seem
well defined from beginning to end
despite a change of than going from a
knowing nuisance to main threat this
allows them to feel more distinct
memorable not in many ways relatable we
either know people like this or have
been people like this compare these two
to modern Disney villains Hans from
frozen and Pete from Toy Story 2 they
start off as seemingly well-defined
characters until the rug
now from under us and we discover that
they were villains the whole time but
the problem is because they do it as a
twist they become completely different
people we have to be reintroduced to
making them less distinct less memorable
and less relatable Gaston and Sid from
beginning to end sound like the same
character it's not right for a woman to
read don't you start getting ideas
thinking one little word now that's all
it takes
never have it your way well we have
waited making it talk in County 10 9
compare how these two sound from
beginning to end when they're evil roots
are revealed I'm thinking the same thing
just like I've been searching my whole
life to find my own place no you're no
match for Elsa I on the other hand in
the hero why the prodigal son has
returned there
I tell you was not safe there tone
mannerisms and even personality seem
very different meaning we can't get a
handle on their character as well these
characters are done a lot with Disney
films recently which is not bad
oftentimes they work outside and help
serve the story or message but when it's
done this many times and with this many
villains not only does it start to get
old but we're kind of losing that
connection to enjoying our dark side
it'll be fine Hans bellwether Otto or
Henry J water new cool villains you
don't enjoy watching them be evil we
just see them as nuisances that get in
the way of our hero now they're good at
being in the way and being roadblocks
but they're not charming fun or
charismatic like these villains on earth
and that's because they weren't allowed
to be villains throughout the majority
of the film so you can't enjoy them as
much in that role we don't get to see
the devilish smirk of Frollo the
gratifying laugh of Jafar the evil just
enjoying being evil of Night on Bald
Mountain that's what makes these
villains so much fun but the fact
remains these are stories that aren't
supposed to belong to the villains
they're supposed to belong to the hero
well the villains have to take a step
backwards
granted a small step to be sure the
heroes and Disney films are much more
interesting and engaging than ever
truthfully these are the people we're
supposed to learn from supposed to look
up to supposed to want to be our message
and characteristics are much more
interesting and complex than that of
dozens of older Disney films while these
older movies are still classics and
using both simplicity and complexity in
the right places
Disney knows they need to evolve people
change rule change and people find
different ways of getting those rules
across one of the more interesting
recent development is that Disney
doesn't always need villains
sometimes it can just be a series of
circumstances and conflicts that have to
be overcome and they don't always tie
into just one individual causing it the
older villains used to be about battling
the grand evil and that no matter how
threatening the danger undying hope and
strength can result in beating it modern
day stories focus on a different kind of
struggle struggles about identity
belonging seeing that things are not
always as black and white as they seem
these are relevant issues and messages
to get across today as their antagonists
have to reflect that in a way that best
fits the story it's not meaning to tone
down the fun of the villains it's just
it's seen as what's needed at the moment
so where Disney's enemy of villains as
great as they used to be no but there's
a good and even at my Roble reason why
the same way Disney is trying to
distance themselves from all their
characters being too similar the same
can be said for changes that are needed
to their villains the important lessons
and creative ways they're trying to get
across those lessons don't always call
for villains like in the old days would
it be nice if some did yes that I hope
they look into that if I have a reason
just variety but Disney is on a hot
streak because they know how to relate
to people and they know how to challenge
and evolve Disney wants to be relevant
and it wants to be helpful and it will
do so in the way that each time period
needs while the evilest of the evil seem
old school now maybe now comeback in the
near future because we always live in
changing times and people's focus and
dilemmas change with those
Disney is always going to do with the
best to follow the dreams and problems
of people and reflect them cinematically
for all agents so who knows what the
future holds
maybe villains will get better maybe
heroes will get better maybe they'll
both get better whatever happens we
still have a long line of baddies was
back on and smile on how they always did
their best to give us their word I'm
going to stop good guy remember so you
don't have
[Music]
hey does Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing the
tragedy assistant program for survivors
taps as it's often called offers
compassionate care to all those grieving
the death of a loved one serving in our
armed forces since 1994 taps has offered
comfort and hope 24 hours a day 7 days a
week for a national peer support network
and connection to grief resources all
letting no cost to surviving families
and loved one TAS has assisted over
70,000 surviving family members casualty
officers and caregivers their national
military survivor seminar and good grief
camp has been held annually since 1994
conducting these at locations across the
country if you know or are someone
suffering the laws of a military loved
one this is definitely worth checking
out and supporting even if you don't
know someone trust me when I say this is
a good cause to go to check out their
website or their YouTube page and see
all the good work you could be helping
out with
[Music]
you